Would chem trail right program be a good option to run if I have been exposed to chemicals and natural gas?
Yes, you could do that. You that would be fine. Now somebody asked last week, you know, what's a good right program to help with detoxification and I want to clarify my answer a little bit.
So, are there frequencies that can help with detoxification? Well, I think there's a lot of misunderstanding around detoxification in the alternative worlds.
So, lots of people think I just need to do a detox. I think that's what I need to do. Just talk to somebody and say I just think I need to do a detox. So it would be a good detox.
The truth is you understand the metabolic pathways. So you got to think like a physiologist. So from a physiological standpoint, your body is always detoxifying.
Your liver is grabbing things out of the blood. It's filtering the blood. So I need it through what are called phase one phase two and phase three pathway and then by need it to bio that's phase three.
And then bio goes into the bio duct ultimately down to the gall bladder and dumps into the small intestine and you hopefully don't reabsorb it. That's the beneficial benefit of binders.
And once it's in the intestines, hopefully you're deposited into the toilet next. That's how you get toxins out of your body. Now, can frequencies help that?
Yes and no. So, can frequencies help the liver can function better? Yes. So there's liver support programs. That might be the best thing.
So, I personally did not write. I personally did not create all the programs. If you have a true right. But with the Atelier Robin, I personally created all those programs.
I don't think I have a chem trail program with the Atelier Robin. If I do, it's all liver frequencies. I can't remember because I wrote like 1800 programs.
It's liver frequencies. There's no such thing as a frequency that's going to grab on to chem trail chemicals, which, first of all, they've never been disclosed, probably. So nobody knows what they are.
And grab on to them and push them out of your body, which is a work that way.
So, how to understand everything functions in your body physiologically, a different metabolic pathways. So, that's chemistry. And it's controlled by neurology. So you have to understand that.
So, do frequencies help with detoxification? Yes and no. So, frequencies can help the liver work better if you're running liver frequencies that can help bring more balance to the liver. It helps the liver cells that parasites actually function better.
But they're not necessarily going to directly speed up detoxification or create a detoxification, you know, accelerated it anyway. And so people think I need to do a detox.
That's what they're saying. But I think what they're thinking is I need to be able to detoxify because I feel toxic. Well, then you have to support all those seven phases of detoxification. That's why I wrote that book. And that's why I created that course because I think there's so much misunderstanding about what detoxification is.
It's run by different genes run by different metabolic pathways. It's all chemistry with under the control of neurology. So, if you really want to help detoxification, you use different nutrients that can help support chemistry.
And you use different therapies that can help with those seven phases were even like a hot pack, a castor oil pack over your liver can help decrease the viscosity of bio, bio thereby allowing the flow of bio to be to be sped up and thereby allowing phase one and phase two to increase because phase three isn't blocking it.
So that's a very physical thing you can do to help with detoxification coffee. And if it's how did they work with detoxification coffee. And I'm going to stimulate the vagal nerve granular head, which is the neurology behind the liver function.
So the liver is controlled by vagus nerve. So if you stimulate the vagus nerve, you're going to help stimulate the phase one phase two pathways in the liver.
But again, if you're not, if your gallbladder is all stuffed up and you're not getting good bio flow, you're not helping things. Or if you're, if your gut is so damaged, because you continue to eat graph foods, you're still absorbing stuff that you get your liver works so hard to get rid of and dump into the small intestine in the first place.
Or if you're constipated, you're not having good bowel movements and emptying your bottles, then you're, you're going to be reabsorbing those things. That's why start at phase six, make sure you're having good bowel, but then phase five, make sure you're binding this stuff in the colon, then phase four, make sure your gallbladder is functioning well in your bio flow is, you know, is moving slow as smoothly as possible.
Then go to phase one, two, three, and you're supporting with copying them is a different things like that and and do specific specific nutrition that I gave you.
Dan and I and root milk to sell and different things like that to help support phase one, two, and three.
And then you could move on to I'm going to use a key later that's going to grab on this stuff in the tissues to help hold it into the blood to get it into the liver to get it into the small intestine to get into the larger just to get into the toilet.
So when somebody says what right program should I use for detox really maybe liver programs, but really that's not that would not be my first go to again, this like any tool, okay, I'm Mr. right fan right because I'm probably the most renowned person in the world on right technology as far as critical use because I've been doing this for so long, but again, you don't use a hammer to put in the screw.
So it will work maybe, but you use a screwdriver that use the best tool possible.
So right for detox is that going to help yeah it's going to help but indirectly you're using rights to kill cancer to kill pathogens, stimulate cell function to stimulate cell health and bring back residents to sell so it can help indirectly by helping the liver.
It's specifically going to pull stuff out of your body so yeah, sorry, long question.